let's continue our tour through the
United States over the last 24 hours
Donald Trump last night held his first
sort of real campaign event this was an
event in Davenport Iowa it was billed as
a major speech about education policy it
ended up being nearly 100 minutes of
Donald Trump ranting and raving confused
and with terrible audio very very little
discussion of Education other than a few
anti-trans statements now I do want to
warn you as we get into these clips the
audio was absolutely terrible it's
possible that antifa snuck in and did
the audio engineering if you haven't
heard of antifa in the next segment you
will be introduced to the ways of antifa
by one of the attend attendees at this
event first and foremost the disconnect
from The Real World continues as Donald
Trump claimed that you need an ID to buy
groceries why don't you need one to vote
you have to have one when you buy
groceries and other things but you can't
have one for voting that's because they
want to cheat that's the only reason now
of course you don't need D to buy
groceries and when I tweeted about this
someone wrote to me and said David if
you use a credit card you do need an ID
to buy groceries no you do not in the
not in the United States in the rare
case when you have a physical card and
you wrote on the back CID and you hand
it to a cashier they might make you show
an ID but overwhelmingly you don't need
any ID whatsoever in any circumstance to
buy groceries unless you are buying
alcohol but Trump wouldn't know that
because he has not I guess bought
groceries in probably decades Donald
Trump went fully conspiratorial during
this supposed speech about education
where he said he will end woke and will
also crush the Deep state
together we will end
the weaponize
forever
we will end woke
we will crush the Deep State there it is
the Deep state which of course is a
conspiracy theory that Donald Trump has
continued to dabble with for a very very
long time one of the strangest moments
during this event
was When Donald Trump pulled the
audience about whether they like their
children very unusual presidential sort
of speech moment does anybody in here
not like their children
oh be careful
oh
we got to be careful with that I mean
Trump doesn't right not not most of them
anyway
the problem is the fake news media is
going to report that as fact you know
that you're going to have a lot of
explaining to do yeah
he loves his boy he loves his family and
as you can tell the audio very very poor
cutting in and out
um at another moment Donald Trump tells
this bizarre story of he would win
basketball
by having LeBron James play on a women's
team which is an interesting idea I'm
not a fan of LeBron James I don't like
LeBron but I'd say hey LeBron
you ever think of becoming a woman
because you're going to be on my team
you're gonna have we're going to go
undefeated for the next five years
LeBron
I'm not a fan but you know I would ask
him that question there it is and I will
not give one penny to any school
that has a vaccine mandate or a mask
mandate that really set the crowd off
the crowd mostly liked the crowd was
very bored throughout 95 percent of the
speech they liked the anti-vax stuff and
they liked the anti-trans stuff Trump
also now regularly using the word insane
asylums falsely claiming that foreign
countries are emptying their insane
asylums into the United States it's not
happening and Trump reflects on the
political correctness of the term insane
asylum
here we go citizens are empty
they're mental institutions they're
insane asylums a word you're not
supposed to use anymore
words you're not supposed to use don't
like Biden I have three words for you
we don't want to be caught an
[Applause]
internet
so two words
insane asylum
a word these are words you're not
supposed to be using anymore it's not
politically incorrect but it's not
politically incorrect I think he means
it's not politically correct but he's as
confused as everybody in the crowd and
that I want people to really understand
this went on for nearly 100 minutes and
then he took questions Trump did go
after Ron DeSantis a little bit he is
unhealthily obsessed with the santis
even though DeSantis hasn't yet
announced a candidacy Trump is daily
talking about DeSantis
okay so remember this Rhonda rhondic
this today
or Rhonda Sanctus strongly opposed
ethanol do you know that right and
we don't even know if he's running but I
might as well tell you if he's not
running I'll say he was fine on ethanol
don't worry about
Trump admitting many of his attacks are
just opportunistic lies strongly opposed
ethanol and fought against it at every
turn and he's going to do that again
because people that
come out early for something that's
where they go that's what it is so you
know you may do something politically
but he was very very bad on ethanol you
fought it all the way and he also fought
against Social Security he wanted to
decimate it and voted against it three
times voting against Social Security
that's a bad one a lot of people don't
know that but yeah now it's also not
exactly true and I've spoken about that
before if you're confused like a lot of
people were dipping in and out of my
live stream last night and saying I
don't understand what this is about even
people who watch the entire speech
didn't know what it was about it didn't
make any sense Trump announcing that he
will be breaking up the Department of
Education by which I think he means
abolishing it which is a very bad idea
in fact this entire speech is sort of
emblematic of the problem with education
in the United States not being regulated
enough at the federal level but in any
case Trump says he'll break up the doe
and then seems confused himself select
somebody who will get the job
in addition I am going to pursue and we
studied it very closely and I was
getting ready to do it pull the trigger
he was about to do it and then he lost
the long-term goal but now it's a
short-term goal of breaking up the
Federal Department of Education and
redistributing
its functions through the states there
you go
I'm gonna break it up soon that'll be
done quickly
I was ready to get it done
I was ready to get it done then we had a
bad election
oh man he was just days away four years
he couldn't get it done he was days from
doing it and then we had a bad election
just like his health care plan Trump
then ended his event in Iowa before
moving to the question phase which was
even worse if you can imagine by
promising to use federal law enforcement
to police cities at any
one state
saying
it worked you
late cities are New York City is a crime
then
Chicago is a crime Den you look at these
great cities Los Angeles San Francisco
you look at what's happening to our
country we cannot let it happen any
longer and one of the other things I'll
do because you know you're supposed to
not be involved in that you just have to
be asked by the governor or the mayor to
come in yeah that's basically the law
the next time I'm not waiting one of the
things I did was let them run it and
we're going to show how bad a job they
do well we did that we don't have to
wait any longer we got to get crime out
of our cities thank you very much for a
good question so he'll send in uh
federal law enforcement to police to
police cities now the legality of that
is very shaky and there are cases when
the federal government can just send in
law enforcement but there have to be
specific activities going on it has to
be things under the purview for example
of the FBI or the DEA or ATF there needs
to be specific expertise or jurisdiction
like organized crime or drug trafficking
or terrorism you can't just say oh we're
going to police Chicago for the hell of
it uh that's the blanket use of federal
forces to police cities and it is not
obvious at all that it is legal but who
cares right who cares so what I wonder
is what's the takeaway from people who
go to a speech like this do they come
you know it was billed as a major speech
on education other than saying I will
end the Department of Education and like
stop transgender whatever that means he
didn't really talk about education so I
wonder do people go to this and then go
home and say wow that was really great
really electric inspirational speech uh
I don't know what the reaction is
especially since people seem so bored by
the hundred minutes of this nonsense now
one other note Trump did take questions
and it went about as poorly as you would
imagine here's one that came from the
crowd
we'll take one or two more go ahead
hello Miss hello Mr President got to be
a good one you know if it's a good one
I'm out of here right if it's a bad one
else I've got to take a couple of more
to get over the stench of the bedroom I
just want to say it's an honor to hear
you speak thank you Paul but my question
for you is what can you do to combat
transgender athletes taking over women's
sports such an important issue well
you've done it here because your
Governor's past legislation you can't no
it's crazy it's it's like how does
people are seriously in favor of having
it done and I don't understand it and I
tell the story of that champion swimmer
and she's there and she's looking up and
down the line she sees friends that
she's been swimming with she's a
champion and then she sees this person
next to her and he's a monster he looks
like Wilt Chamberlain but a little bit
different
she sees the guy has a wingspan she's
like looking up and down then she looks
up wow so do not adjust your television
do not adjust your mobile phone Trump is
not answering the question he's just
ranting confusedly and you know he broke
all these records and it's just a it
doesn't make sense all right there you
go so there is Trump's question and
answer phase we are in for a year of
this folks and it is as dangerous as it
is delusional and as we are now focusing
on this is what Trump said but what
about the attendees at this speech Let's
talk about that next